We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P..
Here is a voicemail I received about potential
Trump vs. Biden debates.
Let's take a listen.
Hey, David, this is Aristotle from Modesto,
California.
I just had a quick question.
What do you think about the debates that will
be happening with Joe Biden and Donald Trump?
Because obviously Joe Biden has emphasized
that and is also excited to debate Trump.
And you think Joe Biden is getting, you know.
Maybe sweep the floor with Trump on the debates
because a display on the show you've covered
that Trump is sweaty and it's very just nervous
and everything.
So do you think Trump give me a nervous wreck?
And that would would that give Joe Biden a
advantage?
Let me know.
And also, I love the show.
OK.
You got cut off there.
But that seemed like it was a very, very worthwhile
praise of The David Pakman Show.
So a couple of different things.
Number one, I don't know if there are going
to be debates.
I at this point, I really don't know.
I said before, I don't care if there are debates.
This is an election where I am uniquely unconcerned
with debates.
We know the differences are so vast between
these candidates that I don't need debates.
I don't need conventions.
I don't I really don't need any of this stuff.
The path forward is very clear.
Now, if we learned anything from the Bernie
vs. Biden debate, remember when the Democratic
primary got down to just Bernie versus Biden,
you had a lot of people saying, oh, my God.
Dementia, Joe, he's going to implode.
Bernie is going to mop the floor with him
and take over the primary.
And it was just like very uneventful.
And Biden did fine enough.
And as we know, he ended up very easily winning
the primary.
In general, the expectation that debates are
going to dramatically turn the race I think
are overblown expectations.
That being said, cognitively, Trump is not
where he was three and a half years ago.
And I readily admit that Joe Biden has also
slowed down, notably over the last 10 years,
you know, since he debated Paul Ryan.
I guess that was eight years ago in 2012.
Joe Biden also he's close to 80 years old
and it's a different Joe Biden.
I don't have any interest in pretending that's
not the case.
So there is always the possibility that either
of a candidate could do sort of self-inflicted
damage due to a poor debate performance.
But anybody suggesting that it's clear that
the debates are going to be so one sided that
it will destroy one candidate's possibilities?
I don't see that as as based, in fact.
And again, I don't know that there are going
to be debates.
We will hopefully learn specifics about that
soon.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about some who are calling for
Biden to simply refuse to debate Trump.
We'll talk about the optics versus the strategy.
And we will talk about these mystery seeds
that Americans are receiving.
I actually received some of these and I have
a story to tell about this.
And we will discuss that and so much more
on today's bonus show.
Two ways to get access to the bonus show.
Become a member.
At Join Pacman dot com or become a patron
at patrie on dot com slash David Pakman show.